[Music]
let's go to charlottesville and talk to
james what's up brother james
dr john it's great to talk to you hey
what's up dude
so i'm gonna try to get through this i'm
in quite a uh a predicament right um
my wife unfortunately was uh diagnosed
with stage four cancer oh
what kind
yeah colon cancer oh gosh
yes and it is absolutely on the rise so
for those who are listening out there
please please please get checked yeah
now my wife when i tell you she was the
absolute epitome of health yeah she was
a long-distance runner
she was winning marathon half marathon
races
and just out of the balloon she gets hit
with stage four colon cancer
what's that what's the timeline
ah
well they said
possibly two years
um they don't know right now
it it depends uh we still have a couple
scans
we need to get through to give us a
little bit more of um of the direction
but currently she's on chemo
and we're also trying some um some
natural supplements
did she have surgery
she did she had surgery um
and
it worked for a little while we thought
but um unfortunately it came back i'm so
sorry man
thank you sir that's a that's a
that is a
car wreck punch in the gut man
it is it is and uh you know we've got
great support
um i've got we've got two young boys who
are uh who are tenants well um but my my
question for you today is i i work for i
honestly it's a fantastic company they
treat me very very well
the benefits are fantastic
and my pay is really good
the only problem is dr john i'm just not
into my work anymore okay
and i don't know if it's because
of
my wife and the situation she's going
through but i i've kind of felt like
this a little bit before she was even
diagnosed
that this just is not me and i'm at a
point now where i literally could just
walk out
but i can't yeah now i have the
opportunity to get back into the family
business
but that would require require us to up
and move from where we currently are to
a different state
[Music]
now i wanted to get your opinion i
wanted to get your expertise um i i just
don't know what to do
and i'm lost i am yeah i'll admit it
well i'm you're just you're a brave
loving husband man
your ability to say that stuff out loud
is hard and
um
you can hear my voice i mean it's yeah
thank you for being brave so
um i'm not gonna use names again i don't
have permission to tell the story um so
i'm gonna be rather vague but
one of my best friends on all of the
planet
um
was married
um to an extraordinary
person
um
who
got brain internal brain cancer and
passed away
um
hung in there a lot longer than
everybody thought and then it went
pretty quick
and i remember calling because i was
thinking about a
wild career shift i was going to either
go to law school or i was going to go
get a phd in psychology and i was going
to do something totally radically
different with my life
and this person
did one of those
jobs
and so i called and said hey i'm
thinking about this and this and what
about this what about this
and here was his answer to me
john none of that matters
and that was the first time my stomach
dropped
and
he was right
so here's why i tell you that
does job satisfaction matter yes you
your body is circling the wagons right
now and you're not your food's gonna
taste different you're gonna lose joy in
almost every facet of your life
yes so that's completely and totally
normal
and there will be seasons when you will
be super husband because that's what you
are and you will turn all the lights on
you'll make sure there's flashlights
everywhere and everybody's smiling and
you'll whiten your teeth
and then you'll have moments when you
are dragged into the abyss
right
fair absolutely okay
so my advice and wisdom would be
what my counselor told me
after a loss in my family
you cannot make a major life decision
for a year
just sit
and
everything is crushing you right now and
the temptation is to start looking
around and finding things to throw rocks
at
because you're going to be raged out
because your wife is beautiful and
healthy and did everything right and
this isn't part of that script
and then you're gonna go through
how
devastatingly
easy stage one colon cancer is to deal
with
and how tragically un difficult stage
four is to deal with
you and me yes
absolutely if they haven't already the
idiots who love you in your life and i
say that with a smile on my face will be
telling you well you should have got
checked wow why didn't you and you're
like thinking i know
and yet here we are right and so
you're gonna get all the well-meaning
advice and all this
my recommendation to you man is to
hunker down with your wife you got a
great company who's taking care of you
financially it's going to help you with
these insane medical bills
and what it's going to give you is a
foundation to walk through the next two
years
so i've been focusing a lot on the
future too so i just need to focus on
day by day
no and no that's the problem but that
hurts me though a lot more when i focus
on the future because i focus on
oh my gosh am i going to have to bury
her because honestly neither one of us
want to be buried in this area yeah we
want to be buried but i don't quite know
where that is yet either yeah so no it's
not this area here's the thing
um
you'll get the single worst slash
greatest gift
the worst gift is that you're gonna have
to
potentially
bury your spouse
yeah and you're gonna have a what
a it's a spiritual like you'll get to
sit and look her in the eye and say
let's walk through this together
absolutely and nobody wants that gift
that's a gift i'm happy to hand back
i don't want to open that i don't want
to unwrap it whatever
and you get to say
with your feet propped up on your front
porch after the sun's gone down because
i know you can't look at each other and
have this conversation and still speak
so where do you want to be buried
yeah
it's gonna feel surreal
right right
and so there's a healthy mix of future
planning you have to be
live in reality
and you want to soak up every last
second
yes
and so yeah getting done before one or
two or three men in your life that you
trust
to rally the troops and say here's what
we're looking at the next 18 to 24
months
i'm gonna need help with x i'm gonna
need help with why and you know what
else you're gonna give them a great gift
because they're sitting there with their
thumbs in the air going uh what do we do
what do we do
i need you to help find a place because
we've chosen
nashville tennessee we've chosen houston
texans we've chosen wherever that's
where we want to buy our plots here's
some money that's your job
and i need some help we're here with the
will i need some help here with right so
you're going to get some guys that i'm
going to call you at 2 a.m sometimes
crying out of the shower and i need you
just to answer the phone
have that conversation with them okay
absolutely and
i mean i i'm like um
yeah ah man
i'm heartbroken man
yeah
yeah
it's tough
tell me about it real quick
funny beautiful
cranky
type a
all the above
[Laughter]
what did she hassle you about most
what does she hassle me about the most
yeah what'd she just hassle you about
who
um
that's a good one i mean she can hassle
me about a lot
what's the big one like i for some
reason i hang up my shirts and i put all
my clothes in the hamper but
i stack my pants up i don't know why ah
the dishes i mean i sometimes i just
leave the dishes there come on j i'm
just kidding
[Applause]
what's her what's the funniest what's
the hardest you ever seen her laugh
um oh gosh when we get
uh her brother will send us pictures of
uh
of the dog or send his picture just fun
pictures and yeah
i mean she'll get a good belly laughs
you know i like to be a comedian too so
i'll uh i'll make her laugh a little bit
she laughs at your jokes my wife doesn't
laugh at my jokes at all
okay hey here here's um you'll have
little ones
we do okay how old
10 and 12. oh jeez
how much do they know
uh they know that the cancer came back
um and they're obviously devastated
they don't know what the extent is and
we just we we
don't want to have that conversation
with them yet okay
i think it's wise to get some data
and some very a very clear path before
you sit down with them
um
here's what would be a great great great
gift
this is a legacy gift okay
okay um i want you and your wife to get
a journal and i want you to begin
writing each other notes
on the daily if you can
okay but how much you love her
what today was
like um
what you miss what's funny what's this
i've thought about the future today and
i'm scared
um
i thought about
you know the last few days and i got
nervous or whatever and i'm wondering if
i'm in all those things i want you to
write that stuff down
because your 10 and 12 year old are
going to be 26 and 24 someday
yes and they're going to sit down with
you over chips and queso and margarita
and they're going to say tell me about
mine
right
and you're gonna be able to say i'll
tell how about she tell you
right
james we love you
i said i wasn't going to do this it
doesn't matter what you say man yeah it
doesn't matter what you say
you're losing the love of your life and
your best friend on planet earth
yeah it's tough what you say doesn't
matter right it's just going to come
so hear me say this you're surrounded by
people who love you
absolutely i appreciate it dr john
i'll walk alongside you through this
whole thing you holler anytime i can be
of help or support you let me know okay
definitely thank you sir god bless you
guys i appreciate it we tell your wife
we love her too
we'll do thank you sir okay all right
blessings to you man take care thank you
sir bye-bye